la beauce et sans relief monotone et
pollué par l'agriculture ces critiques
ont la peau dure mais la maison de la
beauce structure de promotion et
d'animation irait pente en ouvrant les
villages et les fermes beauceronne
durant l'été ont fait du blé tendre
or le blé tendre les enfants vous savez
pourquoi c'est faire le blé tendre
c'est bien sûr pour faire de la farine
car la beauce est un peu le lieu de
naissance de la boulangerie et de la
pâtisserie française c'est aussi un
terroir de production d'huile comme ici
chez les laluque des agriculteurs
heureux de parler de leur profession à
des touristes essentiellement français
je fais partie de l'association tourisme
du loiret qui ne font venir un petit peu
de quarts nous sur les salons plutôt
parisien on a la chance de côtoyer des
personnes qui se disent mais ah bon vous
êtes à une heure de paris
alors on leur dit oui si vous voulez on
la journée vous pouvez faire allez voir
je sais pas musée du safran ou iliev le
chatel ou le château de chamerolles et
puis le soir vous êtes vous êtes reparti
le groupe de visiteurs du jour est
plutôt local certains n'ont fait que
quelques kilomètres pourtant tout sans
la sensation d'avoir réellement fait une
visite touristique mais produit dit et
du terroir
c'est je crois pas c'est très important
de le connaît c'est cd produit qui
permet de valoriser dans quoi on va très
loin vaguement si on s'aperçoit qu'au
tour dans notre région on a énormément
de choses qu'on n'a jamais visité et les
mêmes on va aller visiter à 6,1 km d'ici
la beauce ne va pas concurrencer
chambord ou chansons mais une autre idée
du développement touristique est en
germination ici sur une terre qui a
coutume d'offrir de belles moissons